my name is Brendan Greeley and I
complain about things for Business Week
I know we love Elon Musk we just wait
for this guy to talk but have you
actually read the proposal behind
Hyperloop alpha it's not actually a
product launch or even a product
announcement it's just an idea it's just
a PDF he's not going to build it so what
are we doing here what is this first of
all it's called alpha under the
assumption that there's going to be a
beta gamma calling something alpha
implies a continuity that is not
justified by these 30 unfunded pages of
idea I'm going to read you a sentence
that can only have been produced by elon
musk the quiet supersonic plane
immediately solves every long distant
City pair without the need for vast new
worldwide infrastructure what is the
city pair problem the problem with the
plane as will be the problem with the
train in a tube is that you have to park
and then you have to get to the plane
but before you can get on the plane you
have to get patted down the pat-down
exists you can't magic it away in a tube
we had an interview with BusinessWeek's
ashlee vance i love you ash this is not
about you and i quote i wish i had not
mentioned it i still have to run SpaceX
and Tesla and it's cooking hard I wish I
had not mentioned it really alon you
spent a lot of time on this PDF to wish
that you hadn't mentioned it he doesn't
plan to fund it yet because he says he's
really busy building spaceships and cars
so what he has done is given us a gift
of his own logic it's not a trained in a
tube it's a PDF about a train in a tube
he's a billionaire but this is not where
his billions are going cuz he's busy